ready for this one scp-682 vs scp-835 is  one of the most horrifying scp-682 cross  tests we have logged to date that's  right we have paired the hard to destroy  reptile with the disgusting nightmare  known as  scp-835 a giant carnivorous Coral polyp  made from living human matter when  scp-835 was released the Infectious  Abomination pulled scp-682 into its  massive gullet dragging it down for a  slow and painful digestion surrounded by  the intense pressure and screaming human  faces of the beast's fleshy throat what  was eventually ejected was little more  than 682's skeleton however over time  this skeleton regenerated into a  horrific hybrid of scp-682 and scp-835  covered in sticky tentacles human faces  spewing acid and infectious spores that  could turn others into monsters it  breached containment and killed many the  survivors had to be terminated to avoid  scp-835 contamination spreading further